trois mille hectares de champ
entièrement biologique du maïs sucré aux
carottes en passant par le soya et les
haricots verts plus en notre culture
mieux c'est au point de vue rotation des
cultures au point de vue maladie au
point de vue mauvaises herbes
plus on note que de se mieux c'est ça
fait bientôt 20 ans que gilles audette a
pris le virage bio il est aujourd'hui le
plus gros cultivateurs certifié au
québec mais des fermes bio il y en a
près de 2500 deux fois plus qu'il ya
cinq ans c'est normal qu'elle soit si
enthousiaste caroline halde est une
professeur spécialiste entre autres des
engrais verts on va y revenir et de
l'agriculture biologique alors de voir
que le bio c'est aujourd'hui 8 % des
entreprises agricoles québécoises
on a pris m un engouement en partie dû à
la prise de conscience environnementale
sauf qu'un autre chercheur a posé la
question qui fâche l'agriculture local
et bio est elle vraiment meilleure pour
l'environnement
tant mieux si c'est faire moins 500 ha
sont rentables tant mieux ça valorise
les régions mais si on utilise la vidéo
comme voie privilégiée prémunir et notre
environnement en la bonté
parce que selon les conclusions qu'il
tire des études consulter il y a un
problème avec cette manière de faire
lepoint fr et gex et sa faible
productivité donc l'équation serait
simple puisque le bio demande plus de
surface pour produire la même quantité
qu'en conventionnel
ça laisse moins de place à la nature et
réduire et donc la biodiversité sans
surprise notre cultivateurs n'est pas de
cet avis chacun devra signer pigna ce
qui le gêne c'est que dans le
raisonnement
les pesticides ne sont pas réellement
prises en compte
c'est un point principal parce que les
pesticides ils sont nocifs
au point de vue environnemental ils sont
nocifs au point de vue santé plaisir
points à l'aller
si on enlève un élément de l'équation on
oublie un gros bottin pesticides de
synthèse tout comme les fertilisants de
synthèse sont interdits en bio
[Musique]
confirmation en suisse dans cet institut
qui compare les cultures bio et
conventionnels depuis plus de 40 ans
résultats publiés dans la revue nature
en 2010 9 40% de protoxyde d'azoté en
moins par hectare dans le bio mais pas
de différence pour le maïs avec le
méthane le protoxyde d'azoté
c'est le principal gaz à effet de serre
émis en agriculture
et l'union des producteurs agricoles
qu'est ce qu'elle en pense de ce débat
moi j'ai un bac
il embarque par contre volontiers dans
les transferts de connaissances issues
du bio et qui en fut ans les autres tous
les systèmes mais ça les producteurs bio
qui nous ont amenés à pratiquer cette
façon faire là cette technique l'entente
à peu près trois semaines de trêve voix
est à peu près un match de haut
c'est ça un engrais vert une légumineuse
comme le trèfle par exemple qui a
commencé à pousser ici dès que le blé a
été fauché en fait la tresse fixent
l'azoté de l'air pile mais d'un dans la
planche donc qui peut se décomposer donc
cet azote la voie disponible l'année
prochaine pour la culture du maïs
en tout cas les deux mondes s'accordent
sur un point puisque l'utilisation de
l'espace pose problème il faudrait
surtout réduire la place dédiée à
l'élevage et aux cultures pour les
animaux quand vous êtes dirigé l'aller
les vics ans et plus efficace
injustement diminuer la consommation
générale gilles audette n'est pas contre
de toute façon 80% de sa production est
déjà destinée à la consommation humaine